our series changing the game highlights
extraordinary women who are making a
difference extraordinary is a word here
this month we're celebrating all Asian
American and Pacific Islander Islander
leaders Deepika mutyala remember that
name if you don't know it already my
makeup artist when he cheered you were
coming she goes deeper Casino he created
live tinted Ray Don was going on and on
about you this was in 2018 to make
beauty products for all skin tones so
three years earlier she went viral for
posting a video showing how to use
listen to this red lipstick to cover her
dark under eye circles here's Deepika in
action
I think the neutralization that this
does under your eyes before you put on a
concealer is crazy no need to take any
more than this this is definitely a lot
more than you really need to do but
um just kind of rub it in there
[Music]
look at that look at that look at that
live tinted
10 million dollars in additional funding
you drop the microphone
it's so good because I'm thinking how is
that possibly going to work
here you are you're wandering around
you're looking in the stores and you see
nothing that works for you is is it that
type of story it absolutely is when I
looked at the models and the products
neither of them worked for me and I
remember telling my immigrant father
that I was going to start my own makeup
line and he was like okay that's cute go
study but it's just a very full circle
story to be here now but then did you
try to fit in if you didn't see anything
that looked like you then you thought it
might look like them yeah I dyed my hair
blonde I got blue contacts I wanted to
look like I know I asked him to pull up
a picture of you because you've got like
blonde highlights yeah there she is and
those are blue contact lenses wow yeah
so so your father says uh go go study
right yeah okay I will did he want you
to be a doctor absolutely
Dr Mary and Dr V doctor but you know my
sister my sister for me it's like okay
okay so you I mean I mean you went and
studied how to start a business right
absolutely come up with live tinted
where'd the name come from live tinted
to me the word tint it unites all of us
right you have a tent you have a 10 eye
of a tent I wanted to create a brand
that actually felt really inclusive for
anyone and so live tinted to me as a
mantra I really want people to say it
and believe it and create a brand that
connects all of us the products and the
name yeah so even though you say it's
made for people of color you want
everybody because you know there are
white people everywhere exactly you're
saying this is for them as well yeah and
it's really problem solution oriented
right like that video was hiding dark
circles we have a lot of products that
center around hyperpigmentation so you
can use our SPF men should use SPF but
how did you how did you know the red
lipstick was going to work that's what I
believe it was a makeup artist was using
an actual color corrector on me and I'm
not a makeup artist so as an everyday
girl I was like well wouldn't a red
lipstick do the same thing but it's not
clean so we created products that are
clean and actually help with
hyperpigmentation in dark circles you
know I love the photo of you with the
blonde highlights and the blue contact
lenses so many of us struggle with
identity issues and wanting to fit in
young girls young boys especially and
you were like that but then you decided
look there needs to be products on the
market that allow us to embrace who we
are and you know what's so cool is that
thing that I was so insecure about
growing up having the dark circles being
Indian in my culture and identity it's
actually what made me stand out and
create a whole business posting that
video around the dark circles that I was
so ashamed of changed my whole life yes
now I have a business around and you
were so stunning too stunning honestly
what are your mom you posted a video
recently of your mom who's sort of
bragging about you can we can we show
that John I know we got to go but could
we just show the video of her mom
she's my daughter all these products are
her products this is her pictures I'm so
proud of her company name is
she's Heaven mom and dad are pretty
proud they have to be they absolutely
are they're watching right now hi Mom
and Dad it's my mom and dad they're so
excited it's really cool right to them
the American dream is very different
from me right like to me the American
dream is about changing the way for the
next generation of people to go live out
their wildest dreams for them it was
about safety and respect in America and
I think it's going to take a new
generation of people to show that the
Next Generation they can do it too for
that new generation what is your advice
for entrepreneurs in about 30 seconds
because you're this is the big goodbye
yeah you know I really think it's
embraced that superpower that makes you
stand out like that thing that I was so
scared of is what made me create a whole
company so Embrace that and honestly the
thing to me is I'm one of one and I
think everyone needs to remember that
you have your own unique story so I have
my advice but look in the mirror and
think about what you want to do in the
world and go change the world I'm
cheering you on as long as Mom and Dad
too your daughter did great your
daughter did great uh nice to meet you
by the way I'm wearing is it moisturizer
right now
[Music]